I am involved in the business of wedding
cards for the past 6 years. I have a
doubt about selling wedding cards with
non-Muslim
gods. Is it okay
sir? I have this doubt from the
beginning. Some say it's okay and some
say it's not okay to sell them. Please
sir give me a good knowledge about this.
Thanks.
The question posed is that is it
permissible to sell wedding cards with
photographs of gods of non-Muslims?
Actually the god for Muslim and
non-Muslim is the same as Allah subhanaa
tala. If you're saying that the god with
the non-Muslim worship that's a
different thing. So god of the
non-Muslims is the same Allah subhana wa
tala. God of all human beings Allah
subhanaa tala. But I don't want to
question all that. Can you sell wedding
cards on which there are photos of gods
which are worshiped by non-Muslims? The
answer to this is no. You cannot sell
cards or sell
goods on which there are photographs of
the gods which are worshiped by
non-Muslims. They are doing shik and
you're promoting it. If you're sending
them cards with photographs of the gods
who they think are gods and they worship
and you sell it to them, what are you
doing? you're helping them in shik it's
totally haram and there are various
fatwas of top scholars including that
you cannot wish the non-Muslims during
the festivals you cannot take part in
the celebration you cannot help them to
give them goods in which they are
involved in doing wrong activities
during the festival Allah subhanaa tala
is very clear in surah maida chapter
number 5 verse number two that help one
another in and tawa in righteousness and
piety but do not help one another in f
and ranker. So what are you doing?
You're giving them money with the
photographs of the false gods which they
worship. This is so helping them to do
shik. So you cannot sell any goods which
promote things which are haram and
selling wedding cards or birthday cards
or festival cards which have got
photographs of non-Muslim God is haram
or even selling goods which help them to
celebrate the non-Muslim festivals
encourage them or you're giving a
discount on Christmas saying that
Christmas sale or saying that there's a
Diwali sale and you give discount I am
trying to alert them you can give them
discount with no problem but giving
discount because it's Diwali or giving
discount because it's Christmas trying
to attract customers this is haram as
per the vers of the Quran of surah maida
chapter 5 number two they do not help
one another infin and ranker hope that
answers the